desde este domingo muchos rostros
aparecen descubiertos en las calles de
jerusalén después de un año de
obligación del uso de la máscara es
ahora opcional en exteriores en israel
una liberación que muchos aprecian
estamos felices somos libres es un
milagro me voy a casar dentro de dos
semanas y es muy bonito poder celebrarlo
con todos además sin máscaras las fotos
serán geniales que cada quien haga lo
que le parece correcto el que quiera ir
sin tapabocas bien y quien quiere seguir
usando lo que siga usándolos aún hay
gente que no está vacunada ellos deben
andar con mascarillas sidra el levanta
sus restricciones es gracias a una
campaña de vacunación masiva que ha
reducido considerablemente la
circulación del virus el país tiene
actualmente un promedio de sólo 200
nuevos casos al día más de la mitad de
sus habitantes ya han recibido dos dosis
de la vacuna de facer para los mayores
de 60 años la tasa supera el 80% en
efecto a cambio de datos médicos sobre
los efectos del medicamento en su
población
el grupo farmacéutico yo prioridad al
estado hebreo
este año la asociación entre fighter x
israel ha producido otro logro pionero
juntos estamos demostrando que mediante
la vacunación masiva podemos vencer la
pandemia de kobe 19 y salvar vidas
este domingo también marca la reapertura
total de las escuelas del país además a
finales de febrero los clientes ya
habían vuelto a los restaurantes y
gimnasios y las re aperturas continúan a
partir de finales de mayo los turistas
vacunados podrán volver a visitar israel